echemos un vistazo echemos un vistazo a
las salidas a los gastos a la inversión
para así contar bueno ver cómo es
contado y ver cómo es medido el producto
interno bruto para ver qué tan activas
son las diferentes partes que conforman
a la economía así que quizá la
definición es el valor de mercado de
todos los bienes y servicios finales
producidos no solamente intercambiados
producidos en un país dentro de un
periodo determinado ahora la ley
representa al producto interno bruto no
no tengo idea por qué pero la iv lo
representa ahora veamos veamos todo esto
desde un punto de vista de gastos gastos
entonces qué piezas conforman al
producto interno bruto bueno pues veamos
que quienes son las personas quienes son
los jugadores que compran que gastan
dinero en bienes y servicios finales
dentro de un país bueno tenemos a las a
las fábricas por ejemplo las fábricas
gastan dinero en bienes y servicios
finales también tenemos
a los dueños a los dueños de las
fábricas a las personas gastan dinero en
bienes y servicios finales dentro de un
país en un tiempo determinado y también
tenemos al gobierno el gobierno gasta
dinero también en cosas para el país así
que tenemos a las fábricas ocupantes de
casa el gobierno quien más usemos la
imaginación quien más quien más ha bueno
también por ejemplo podemos suponer que
intercambiamos que hacemos comercio con
otros países entonces aquí pongo aquí
pongo compras foráneas y compras por
anne as porque bueno a esto se puede ver
como exportación podemos suponer que
nosotros exportamos a otro país y ellos
hacen la compra de nuestro producto
ahora observamos bien todo esto porque
por ejemplo puede haber gastos gastos
que hagan las fábricas los ocupantes de
casa el gobierno en bienes y servicios
finales bueno bienes y servicios
producidos dentro de otro país entonces
no todos los gastos son en nuestro país
así que tendríamos que restarle esos
gastos de bienes y servicios producidos
en otro país
y para que así se cumpla de la
definición del producto interno bruto
así que a todos estos gastos le vamos a
restar lo que son los productos foráneos
menos los productos foráneos porque son
cosas producidas son bienes y servicios
producidos fuera de nuestro país y la
definición dice dentro de nuestro país
así que es lo mismo que importaciones
son las importaciones menos las
importaciones si observamos los gastos
en bienes y servicios producidos en un
país en un tiempo determinado y hacemos
la suma de todos esos gastos de las
fábricas de los ocupantes de casa del
gobierno las exportaciones que se
hicieron a otros países
si hacemos la suma de todos estos gastos
en bienes y servicios y le restamos las
importaciones obtenemos una muy buena
aproximación de lo que mide el producto
interno bruto de hecho más o menos así
es como se mide es muy buena manera de
medir los bienes y servicios producidos
dentro de un país ahora los economistas
miden el producto interno bruto de la
manera siguiente ellos dicen y es igual
a iu de inversión ahora inversión no lo
definimos aquí
y como lo definimos en términos usuales
de hecho vimos eso en otro vídeo de
macroeconomía lo que realmente esa
inversión son los gastos de las fábricas
para hacer para producir nuevos bienes y
servicios entonces eso a eso realmente
es lo que se le considera inversión
ahora por parte de los ocupantes de la
casa se le considera solamente inversión
a comprar casas nuevas y ya todo lo
demás el volumen el volumen del gasto
total del ocupante de la casa a eso se
le considera consumo ahora por parte del
gobierno sus gastos serían por ejemplo
salarios de policías militares limpiar
la ciudad mantenerla limpia que otra
cosa crear parques por ejemplo o
mantenerla la casa blanca limpia es otro
otro gasto del gobierno y todo eso va
directo a ge gastos de gobierno ahora
ojo con este otro este lado de aquí las
exportaciones menos importaciones esto
lo podemos visualizar o ver como como
exportaciones netas exportaciones netas
ahora si este número
es positivo entonces quiere decir que
estamos exportando más de lo que estamos
importando sin embargo si es negativo
estamos importando más de lo que estamos
exportando así que es bastante sencillo
tomar en cuenta si es positivo o
negativo que el lado que lado tiene más
más peso a esto se le conoce
tradicionalmente como exportaciones
netas y como puedes ver estas palabras
están sumamente relacionadas quizás con
las versiones intuitivas con las que
iniciamos y ya echándole un vistazo a
todo esto del producto interno bruto
desde una perspectiva de gastos
veremos ejemplos en los que en los que
afecta a la inversión al consumo vamos a
ver casos que afectan a estas clases